hey this is pretty interesting from a
Joe Rogan episode earlier this week now
I know that a lot of people want to talk
about Joe Rogan say he'd saying he'd
vote for Trump / Biden that's a
different story that's not today's topic
I hope to be able to talk to Joe
personally about the Trump Biden thing
soon but for today I want to play some
clips for you of Republican congressman
dan Crenshaw on Joe Rogan's program
earlier this week and in the context of
coronavirus they got to talking about
health care and Dan Crenshaw rolled out
just about every bad argument about
health care and what I really liked
about this is how Joe Rogan ended up
kind of de-facto destroying the
arguments that Dan Crenshaw was making
but in a way that was just completely
genuine it wasn't calculated with
talking points and what I mean by that
is Joe Rogan is more of a political
hobbyist than a political analyst and he
even said recently when I say I think
I'd vote Trump over Biden I don't know
what I'm talking about and he actually
said go you know listen to people he
actually listed the David Pakman show go
listen to people who really are doing
this full-time he doesn't consider
himself a political expert i dub it more
of a political hobbyist and joe has said
many times politics is not his main
thing he's interested in it he has
opinions he talks to people but he's not
a politics guy so what's interesting to
me about the clips that I'm gonna play
for you is that Dan Crenshaw is making
bad argument after bad argument
arguments that have a lot of history in
different political circles as being the
types of talking points you want to use
and Joe dismantles them not bike
trotting out his own crafted talking
points but just by kind of reacting in
real time with common sense to the
nonsense that Dan Crenshaw was saying so
let's get right into it I think you'll
find this interesting first here is Dan
Crenshaw trotting out a popular argument
from libertarians including people like
Rand Paul which says Medicare for all or
single-payer reduces freedom and it's
sort of enslaves doctors they argue
we're not free with Medicare for all and
Joe Rogan makes pretty quick work of it
and you'll see Dan Crenshaw become
visibly confused and sort of start
jumping around with non sequiturs trying
to retort but failing when we talk about
men
care for all it tries to it tries to
move past these essential foundations
whether of a free society that we have
to adhere to and and and because the
other thing I I push back on a little
bit is the health care as a right
statement and I push back against that
because with that when you're calling
something a right what you're
effectively saying is that somebody else
has a obligation to serve you and it's
hard to call something a right when that
right requires the service of somebody
else
don't make II don't we already do that
with the firemen don't we do that with
the police department don't we do that
with public schools not exactly no I
mean we have public services that I
would I would distinguish those public
services from something like a reckless
quantum of care and I would distinguish
them to it to an enormous extent like
but here's why you can add a few hundred
thousand more people to a you know to to
the nation's population and it doesn't
change the mission of the military right
like it doesn't it doesn't take an away
thing away from them but these but
because of this sort of non-rival this
is like an economics term but the sort
of non-rival attribute of these things
it is different right because there's
only a select number of doctors and
we've already said that once you put
price controls in there's going to be
less doctors because doctors will be
paid less it'll get burned out more
they'll then Possible's will be able to
actually never finish that point so Dan
tries to slip in this is an economic
term implying you know a lot of people
don't know this term but this is an old
libertarian argument that's a really bad
argument so so here's the deal
single-payer doesn't make doctors slaves
and it doesn't take away freedom in fact
we already have the emergency medical
treatment and active Labor Act which
mandates that hospitals must provide
stabilizing emergency treatment to
patients in a dire emergency situation
or delivery services to a woman who is
in active labor period no matter whether
they can pay or not no matter whether
they have insurance if you're an ER
doctor
someone comes in with an emergency you
must give them stabilizing treatment
this has been around 34 years since 1986
back then you had some people saying
you're enslaving doctors but you're not
and it's a bad argument consider lawyers
everyone has a right to an attorney even
if you can't afford one you have a right
to an attorney
our attorneys slaves our attorneys
enslaved by that no now does any one
lawyer have to take a certain case no
typically not does any one doctor have
to treat a specific patient under
single-payer no more than the general
responsibilities to the Hippocratic oath
and to provide emergency stabilizing
treatment which dates back 34 years bad
argument let's continue the reason price
controls reduce supply and we reason we
see supply reductions in other countries
is because well hospitals don't get the
same amount of money they're not going
to invest in that extra ICU but they're
not going to buy those extra ventilators
they're not going to hire those other
doctors a doctor doesn't want to be a
doctor because they don't make the
amount of money that they thought they
would make they're doing extra work
because there's more people who now have
access to them but there's less of them
so wait lines are huge and then and
they're seeing multiple more patients a
day doctor burnout increases quite a bit
that's the quick answer as to why why
that happens but does that kind of
answer your question now here I really
need you to understand this is a gift
alop Dan Crenshaw is throwing about four
to five different arguments at Joe Rogan
none of them makes sense none of them
are actually arguments against
single-payer and now he's moved beyond
single-payer and is starting to talk
about reimbursement rates doctor
compensation that's one issue many
countries have successful systems but
they've got to figure out doctor
compensation that's that's just one
issue then Dan Crenshaw throws
single-payer will increase demand and
every hospital is going to be full
that's an old tired argument when you
give everyone healthcare it doesn't
increase demand in total it shifts
demand from people using emergency rooms
and waiting until things are more
serious to people going and getting
checked out or
going to their pre CP instead of the ER
and that actually can in many ways
lighten the load on emergency rooms and
emergency care and reduces the serious
conditions because people get checked
out earlier so Dan Crenshaw here makes
so many different arguments in 30
seconds that it's hard to keep up now
let's skip forward to Joe reacting to
this
it's getting really that does yeah the
human right issue we we kind of moved
around with that this the idea that it's
different than the fire department or
the police department or well it's not a
right either actually the the fire
department's not necessarily a a right
as we would but it's a public service
that's provided to everyone now it is
but it but understand so let's call it a
public service then and let's call
doctor healthcare a public service okay
well if we were to do medicare for all
but wouldn't the result be the same if
it's provided for everyone not from a
practical standpoint just because it's
much easier again you could add a
hundred thousand people more to your
city and the fire department would have
marginally more more work to do Dan
Crenshaw says not from a practical
standpoint but actually yes Joe is right
it would be the same thing from a
practical standpoint it would be
different from an ideological standpoint
where you know Dan Crenshaw's ideology
makes health care different than being a
firefighter but in practical terms it is
basically the same thing as Joe Rogan
points out let's skip ahead a little now
and this is just bad from Dan Crenshaw
and Dan does something slippery Dan
starts talking about socialism as a
system more broadly rather than just
talking about health care Joe's talking
about health care and then this is just
amazing remember how in the clip I
played for you Joe Rogan was saying
health care for everyone as a public
service or a right or whatever you call
it it's like firefighting it's like
police or public education or whatever
and back five minutes earlier Dan
Crenshaw argued no no no health care is
different now in this clip only a few
minutes have gone by and Crenshaw says
no Medicare for all isn't socialism it's
a public good that's right Dan
that's what Joe said five or six minutes
earlier when you said no it's different
take a look right so we're talking about
over what you're talking about socialism
overall not just over I'm not just
involving medicine you're talking about
socialism in general and I'm saying
isn't the fire department an example of
socialism that works it's definitely not
an example of socialism I think it's an
example of a public good the way the
military is an example of a public good
the way the highways are examples of
public goods the way parks are exam
right but they are funded by the people
it's funded by people overall it doesn't
cost people money to use them and the
people have these as a basic part of our
society and our civilization Dan
Crenshaw is just a human pretzel here
he's completely wound up into knots when
Joe says it's a public good like these
others Crenshaw says no it's different
five minutes later when Rogan says
aren't we socializing an element of the
economy and an element of society that
works fine to socialize Crenshaw says no
no no it's not socialism it's merely a
public good well okay why didn't you
agree with Joe when he said that five
minutes earlier
here's Crenshaw's last reaction and
Crenshaw he basically white flags and he
plays these pedantic semantic games and
says at the end these are really just
semantic issues no I understand that and
I have nothing no promise that I just I
just would not call them socialist what
would you call the fire how does it get
funded it's a public good how does it
get funded it's a public good it's
funded by the public right and it's just
it's not it's but it's not relying on
these sort of it's not relying on the
tenants of socialism to function and so
that now we're now we're kind of having
a discussion of definitions and this is
an important discussion to have because
oftentimes even Democrats aren't really
talking about socialism well even during
already Sanders doesn't call it
socialism he's talking about democratic
socialism and he makes some very clear
distinctions between the two of them
which I think you could apply to things
like the fire department or the police
department yeah there's a lot in that so
there's a lot there and I'm not going to
subject you to more of this but I like
this for a few different reasons number
one they try to stay
ideological claims when they can but
when Joe Rogan's breaks down those
claims with simple questions they
retreat to semantic games and Gish
galloping which is just throwing out so
many different assertions that it
becomes very difficult to keep track of
them and actually refute them one by one
that's a sign that the facts aren't on
your side but number two you all know
I've been critical of some elements of
Medicare for all plans there are issues
around cost estimates and other issues
with a lot of these plans I would
actually love it if the left and right
could simply agree on what we know which
is Medicare for all will increase access
and Medicare for all can maintain or
increase quality the question is at what
cost will we be able to maintain quality
and increase access to 100% the
coronavirus stimulus has proven when we
want to we can find two trillion we can
find six trillion we can find ten
trillion if we want to the money is
there if we decide we are going to do it
I would much rather be able to move past
these childish arguments that Dan
Crenshaw is laying out which Joe Rogan
exposes as really very bad arguments
let's get our hands dirty and do the
nitty gritty work of figuring out how
this can all work because it can work
it's a question of at what cost and how
to best optimize it let me tell you real
quick about one of our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you 15% off
when you go to david pakman.com slash
cuts that see UTS because solid color
t-shirts are a really important staple
in pretty much every guy's wardrobe I
think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing t-shirts from cuts
clothing have been a game changer for me
and as a company all they deal with are
men's
solid color t-shirts so they actually
put a ton of thought into the comfort
the style the durability of the t-shirts
they make they fit perfectly they're not
scratchy they don't shrink they don't
fade they don't stretch out over time
like so many other t-shirts they're
really the most comfortable t-shirts
I've owned
and they look great this right here that
I'm wearing on YouTube is the split hem
crew neck t-shirt very soft fits me
perfectly it's the ideal length go take
a look at what they offer and once you
have it you are really going to see and
feel the difference their slogan is it's
the only shirt worth wearing you will
see why and you'll get 15% off when you
do it by going to david pakman.com slash
cuts that's david pakman.com slash c UTS